the two places where I feel most free
aren't actually places they're moments
the first is inside of dance somewhere
between rising up against gravity and
the feeling that the air beneath me is
falling in love with my body's weight
I'm dancing and the air is carrying me
like I might never come down the second
place that I feel free is after scoring
a goal on the soccer pitch my my body
floods with the chemical that they put
inside of epi pins to revive the dead
and I am weightless race less my story
is this I'm a curator at a Contemporary
Art Center but I don't really believe in
art that doesn't bleed or sweat or cry I
imagine that my kids are gonna live in a
time when the most valuable commodities
are freshwater and empathy I love pretty
dances and majestic sculpture as much as
the next guy but give me something else
to go with it lift me up with the
aesthetic sublime and give me a practice
or some tools to turn that inspiration
into understanding and action for
instance I'm a theatre maker who loves
sports when I was making my latest piece
pelota I thought a lot about how soccer
was a means for my own immigrant family
to foster a sense of continuity and
normality and community within the new
context of the u.s. in this heightened
moment of xenophobia an assault on
immigrant identity I wanted to think
through how the game could serve as an
affirmation 'el tool for
first-generation America
in immigrant kids to ask them to
consider movement patterns on the field
as kin to migratory patterns across
social and political borders where the
footballers are not immigrants in the US
play on endangered ground I wanted to
help the kids understand that the same
muscle that they use to plan the next
goal can also be used to navigate the
next block for me freedom exists in the
body we talk about it abstractly and
even divisive lis like protect our
freedom build this wall they hate us
because of our freedom we have all these
systems that are beautifully designed to
incarcerate us or deport us but how do
we design freedom for these kids I
wanted to track the idea back to
something that exists inside that no one
could take away so I developed this
curriculum that's part poli-sci class
part soccer tournament inside of an Arts
Festival
if accesses Pelotas field of inquiry to
create a sports based political action
for young people the project is called
moving and passing it intersects
curriculum development site specific
performance and the politics of joy
while using soccer as a metaphor for the
urgent question of enfranchisement among
immigrant youth imagine that you are a
15 year old kid from Honduras now living
in Harlem or you're a 13 year old girl
born in DC to to Nigerian immigrants you
love the game you're on the field with
your folks
you've just been practicing dribbling
through cones for like 15 minutes and
then all of a sudden a marching band
comes down the field I want to associate
the joy of the game with the exuberance
of culture to locate the site of joy in
the game at the same physical coordinate
as being politically informed by art a
grass laden theater for liberation we
spend a week look
how the midfielder would explain black
lives matter or how the goalkeeper would
explain gun control or how a defender
style is the perfect metaphor for the
limits of American exceptionalism as we
study positions on the field we also
named and imagined our own freedoms no
man soccer is like the only thing on
this planet that we can all agree to do
together you know it's like the official
sport of this spinning ball I want to be
able to connect the joy of the game to
the ever moving footballer to connect
that moving footballer to immigrants who
also moved in sight of a better position
among these kids I want to connect their
families histories to the Bliss of a
goalscorers run family like that feeling
after the ball beats the goalie the
closest thing going to freedom thank you
[Applause]